SPEAK TO THE REPORT YESTERDAY
MORE THAN MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN
ANYTHING TOTALLY EXONERATES ME.
THE END RESULT WAS WRONG.
IF THERE WAS TOTAL BIAS, WHEN
YOU LOOK AT PETER STRZOK AND
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT ME AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT COMEY, SO IT WAS A
PRETTY GOOD REPORT BUT I WOULD
SAY THE IG BLEWETT AT THE END
WITH THAT STATEMENT.
PETER STRZOK SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FIRED A LONG TIME AGO AND OTHERS
SHOULD HAVE BEEN FIRED.
THE TOP PEOPLE WERE HORRIBLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED,
THEY WERE PLOTTING AGAINST MY
ELECTION.
>> OF THIS REPORT CONTAINS NO
EVIDENCE TO MAKE ANY REASONABLE
PERSON CONCLUDE THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION IS
ANYTHING OTHER THAN INDEPENDENT,
IMPARTIAL, AND JUST AS IMPORTANT
TODAY AS IT WAS BEFORE THIS
REPORT WAS ISSUED.
>> Bret: IT WAS SURREAL, THE
PRESIDENT WALKING OUT ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
INTERVIEW LIVE ON
"FOX & FRIENDS" AND HOLDING A
GAGGLE WITH THE PRESS.
AND THAT'S A FIRST TIME THAT HAS
EVER HAPPENED WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND HE MADE
A LOT OF NEWS TODAY.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
JOINING ME HERE AT SHINNECOCK
HILLS, JIM HAMMER,
MELISSA FRANCIS, AND IN
WASHINGTON, MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
AND IN NEW YORK, BILL
McGOVERN, MAIN STREET
COLUMNIST FOR THE WALL STREET
DURING YOUR
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
SO THAT HAPPENED DURING YOUR
HOUR AND CONTINUED INTO YOUR
HOUR.
HOW ABOUT YOUR INSIGHT?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS REMARKABLE.
IT WAS MY SENSE, WHEN HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, THAT HE WAS THE ONE
WHO IS GOING TO RUN AS
COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT, THAT
HE WAS GOING TO BE HIS PRESS
SECRETARY, NOT LITERALLY BUT
FIGURATIVELY AS COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
AND MUELLER SORT OF TOOK THAT
BAG CLUB OUT OF HIS BAG, SO TO
SPEAK.
WITH THE ECONOMY MOVING THE WAY
IT IS, I THINK WITH THE
SINGAPORE SENATE BEHIND HIM AND
THE IG REPORT, AND, I BELIEVE HE
WOULD MUCH RATHER HOLD A PRESS
CONFERENCE ONCE A WEEK IF HIS
LAWYERS UP TO THIS POINT HAD
ALLOWED IT.
>> Bret: MOLLY, THERE IS A LOT
OF LOW-HANGING FRUIT IN THIS IG
REPORT IF YOU ARE A TRUMP
SUPPORTER.
I HAVE PEOPLE WHO SAID THEY WERE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
CHARACTERIZATION, THAT IT WAS A
NOTHING BURGER FROM THE START.
>> I HAVEN'T READ ALL 158 PAGES.
CHUCK SCHUMER IS WRONG ABOUT
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THIS REPORT,
IT WAS AN EXHAUSTIVE DETAILED
LOOK AT WIDESPREAD CORRUPTION,
BIAS, POOR JUDGMENT, BAD
DECISION-MAKING.
THE SAME PEOPLE WERE INVOLVED IN
THE CLINTON PROBE AS WERE
INVOLVED IN WHAT HAS NOW BECOME
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT PEOPLE
WERE SAYING, HOW THEY WERE
OPENLY CONSPIRING AGAINST THE
DONALD TRUMP ELECTION AND HOW
THEY WERE FANTASIZING ABOUT HIS
IMPEACHMENT AFTER THE ELECTION,
THAT REALLY CALLED INTO QUESTION
WHAT COULD HE CAME INTO THE
BASIS OF THE ENTIRE PROBE.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF TREASON
AND COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA AND A
LOT OF EVIDENCE OF THAT BEHAVIOR
BY THE FBI.
>> THE OTHER NEWS MADE TODAY WAS
ABOUT CHINA.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID AND CHINA'S
REACTION.
>> WE WILL DO $50 BILLION ON
$50 BILLION OF HIGH TECHNOLOGY
EQUIPMENT AND OTHER THINGS
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
SO MUCH OF OUR SECRETS -- WE
HAVE THE GREAT BRAINPOWER IN
SILICON VALLEY, AND CHINA AND
OTHERS STEAL THOSE THOSE.
>> WE WILL IMMEDIATELY RESPOND
AND TAKE NECESSARY MEASURES TO
DEFEND OUR IMMEDIATE RIGHTS AND
INTERESTS.
>> Bret: AND MELISSA, WHAT ARE
WE LOOKING AT HERE, IT IS AT
HEADING OUT TO THE TRADE WAR?
>> MARKETS WENT DOWN RIGHT AWAY
ON THIS NEWS AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY THEY CLAWED THEIR WAY
BACK.
THERE'S ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND WHEN WE ARE LISTENING TO
ALL THIS CHATTER ABOUT THE TRADE
WAR.
THERE WAS A MOMENT AT THE G7
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID, WHY
DON'T WE DROP ALL OF OUR TARIFFS
ON EVERYTHING IN IT IT WENT OVER
LIKE A LEAD BALLOON.
THAT'S WHERE HE HAD SAID TO COME
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT NO TARIFFS
ARE BEST.
FOR CONSUMERS AND WORKERS, IT'S
A TRUE FREE MARKET.
BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT FOR A
LONG TIME AND WE CONTINUE TO USE
BOTH THE CARROT AND STICK TO GET
CLOSER TO THAT.
BUT THAT'S THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER AND WHEN HE SAID THAT IT
WAS REVEALED THAT HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN TARIFFS BUT HE ALSO
KNOWS IT WILL TAKE A LOT TO PUSH
OTHER COUNTRIES THERE.
>> Bret: BILL, HOW DOES THAT
PLAY ON MAIN STREET?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FEW
MORE KARATS RATHER THAN THE
STICKS.
I WAS ALSO HARDENED BY THE NO
TARIFFS CALL THE PRESIDENT MADE,
BUT IF YOU WERE SERIOUS ABOUT
THAT, I THINK WHAT HE SHOULD
DO -- NEGOTIATE WITH A PARTNER
LIKE BRITAIN OR EVEN CANADA,
FIND A PARTNER THAT HAS VERY FEW
TRADE ISSUES WITH US.
NEGOTIATE THE IDEAL BILATERAL
AND THEN SAY, THIS DEAL IS OPEN
TO ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS THE
SAME TERMS.
I THINK THAT IS A MORE EFFECTIVE
WAY OF DOING IT AND IT'S MORE
WITH THE CARROT AND THE STICK.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK
IMMIGRATION.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ABOUT THAT THIS MORNING.
>> I'M LOOKING AT BOTH OF THEM.
I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T HAVE SIGNED
THEM.
I NEED A BILL THAT GIVES THIS
COUNTRY TREMENDOUS BORDER
SECURITY, I HAVE TO HAVE THAT.
>> DOES THAT MEAN THE WALL?
>> IF THERE IS NO WALL, THERE IS
NO BILL.
>> WE ARE WAITING FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO CLARIFY HIS
COMMENTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT ASKED THIS
HOUSE TO ACT.
EVERYBODY SAID TO THE PUBLIC, WE
WANT TO WORK IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY.
WELL, YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO IT.
AND YOU HAVE RETREATED.
>> Bret: THERE IS SOME HEART
FAILURE ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY
AND THE WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT THIS AFTERNOON.
THE PRESIDENT SUPPORTS BOTH
BILLS AND IN THIS MORNING'S
INTERVIEW HE WAS COMMENTING ON
THE DISK CHARGE POSITION IN THE
HOUSE, NOT THE PACKAGE.
SO STRAIGHTENING THAT OUT, IT IS
IMPORTANT.
>> I HAVE HALF AN EYE ON A A
MIDTERM ELECTION THAT IS FIVE
MONTHS FROM NOW AND IT'S MY
SENSE THAT NONE OF THIS MOVES
UNTIL THEN.
PERHAPS DEPENDING ON THE OUTCOME
IN NOVEMBER, WE GET MORE
MOVEMENT ON THIS.
I THINK THE TALK RIGHT NOW IS
JUST THAT.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT BALANCE OF
POWER.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE THIS
ATTENTION IS.
>> HE SAID THE MODERATE BILL
WOULD MAKE SENSE SO WHY GIVE UP
LEVERAGE?
WALK BACK FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS CURIOUS AND THEY ARE SAYING
THAT THIS DOES HAVE THE THE FOUR
PILLARS THAT TRUMP SOUGHT BUT IT
DOESN'T WATER DOWN CHAIN
MIGRATION, AND IT ALSO EXPANDS
AMNESTIES IN A WAY THAT IS
REALLY DANGEROUS, IN A MUCH
WHERE PEOPLE WHO ARE CHILDREN OF
FOREIGN WORKERS WILL BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR AMNESTY.
THAT'S AN UNCONTROLLED PROGRAM
AND I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
SHOULD LOOK A LOT ABOUT WHY THEY
ARE REALLY TRULY ONBOARD WITH
THIS, OR WHETHER THEY ARE GIVING
UP WAY TOO MUCH AND LOSING THEIR
LEVERAGE.
>> BOTH SIDES ARE SAYING, THE
OTHER SIDE IS PREVENTING THEM
FROM GETTING BILL DOWN I BILL
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT MAY PUSH PAST
ELECTION DAY.
>> I THINK THAT HAS BEEN THE
HISTORY.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER, I
WAS IN THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
WITH A BIPARTISAN DEAL FELL
APART.
IT'S VERY HARD TO GET
IMMIGRATION THROUGH AND I THINK
SOME PEOPLE WOULD RATHER HAVE
THE ISSUES AND HAVE IT RESOLVED.
THERE SHOULD BE A PRETTY EASY
PATH AT LEAST ON DACA OR
SOMETHING TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT
HIS WALL, WHICH HE WON'T BACK
DOWN ON, IN EXCHANGE FOR SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT DEMOCRATS WANT.
>> LAST THING, WHERE WE BEGAN.
HE TOOK OVER THE NEWS CYCLE, HE
OWNED THE DAY BY THAT HOUR ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT DOING THAT?
YOU MADE THE POINT EARLIER TODAY
THAT IT HASN'T HAPPENED.
YOU SAID IT'S THE KIND OF
PRESIDENCY WE WILL HAVE TO HAVE,
AND THEY LOOK LIKE A FRENZIED
TEAM OF, I DON'T KNOW WHAT,